The joe rogan experience last night set was particularly,
uh,
rich and ideas and some of the new things that I've been working on are,
um,
there's a lot of stuff in,
I'm worth on about this sort of a weirdness of progressive thought later,
like this really aggressive progressiveness that's going on where people are
denying reality and they're doing it so because they feel like people have been
marginalized in the past,
which is true,
but it doesn't mean you spring it back the other way.
You say bunch of stupid shit.
It doesn't make any sense.
Oh,
you judge people too harshly for judging people harshly.
It's like,
yeah.
How does that work,
right.
Getting people for hitting.
Exactly.
Some of the most aggressive people I know are liberals,
so it's really strange.
I mean,
there's an amazing video of,
of University of Toronto,
of this guy who was speaking about men's rights waterfowl.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
These feminists are protesting these students screaming in their face.
The students that want to go see this man talk about women's of,
about men's rights and about that you hate women and all this and they're
incredibly aggressive.
The only hate IC is in the protesters,
the only not going be,
and by the way,
incredibly ignorant to what this guy,
his actual words are.
And they weren't even aware.
They didn't even bother doing the research.
They didn't even bother formulating a true opinion on these this guy's ideas.
They just decided that this guy hates women.
And that's a weird thing.
Like I've had made some posts about feminism on online before and one of the
things that I've found it incredibly strange is that I got called an Mra
asshole.
And so I go,
what does that,
what does that mean?
What's the Mra?
So that I had a very simplified English.
I didn't know what it meant at all.
It's men's rights advocate or activist.
Yeah,
we're activity.
And I was like,
wait a minute,
I'll feminist.
A person who wants equal rights for women is saying that being a man who wants
equal rights for men is an idiot.
Or I could call the Dodo and Mra Dodo and like,
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Well,
Yoga,
well,
they had a compressive Socratic arguments.
I could call it MRI asshole.
[inaudible].
I didn't even know what an MRI,
I mean,
I'm not immense rights advocate and by any stretch of the imagination,
I don't visit any blogs.
I don't visit any forums,
but I'm a believer in equality.
Is,
is as far as like the laws and regulations as they apply to human beings.
And I do not believe that the laws and regulations as they apply to human beings
in this country aren't even for men as the art and women.
I don't think they're even for women and I don't think they're even for men.
Yeah.
If an area,
forcible laws are fucking horrendous for men and some of them are atrocious,
some of them are Canada,
are God awful.
Dave Foley for the longest time,
I don't know if he's resolved.
Horrible,
horrible.
Anybody who's listening to this,
just Google Day Foley,
Joe Experience divorce.
And there's a,
there's a youtube video that someone compiled of just him talks about his
divorce.
He will make your head spin and,
and I know they'll probably be honest TV because what he lost $10 million fund
his last divorce.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause he said it's not alimony.
It's all your money.
That's a,
it is.
It is.
It's insane.
And that's not fair.
It's not fair.
I don't care what anybody says.
I think that absolutely.
If a man and woman get divorced and manage,
get child support.
Absolutely.
And if the woman was not working during the time of the marriage,
I think there should be some sort of compensation.
Something Fair.
It's something recent.
Yeah.
Some of the assets that he developed by focusing on whatever.
Yeah,
sure.
Absolutely.
But that's a terrible payments.
That's just not right.
No,
it's not.
It's not right.
And I have a friend who has to pay his ex wife.
Um,
they were,
they were married for 12 years.
He has to pay her for the rest of her life until she gets married.
So she plays this game.
She has a boyfriend and the boyfriend of her and he sends a,
the investigators over to figure it out and the boyfriend's not there and then
he leaves and the,
the rescuers leaving in the boyfriend moves back in.
And so he has to continue paying her.
Like she's cohabitating with a man and he still has to continue to send her
money.
And it's just a manipulation of the legal system.
And this guy has paid her millions and millions and millions of dollars.
She's in his $4 million Pacific Palisades home.
It crippled him financially.
And on top of that he had to pay for her lawyer whether they want to,
it's gone through divorce and here's where it gets really crazy.
She went to every lawyer in town and consulted with them,
every good lawyer in town that she knew of so that he could never use them as
counsel.
Oh.
Because they'd be conflict of interest.
But some madness.
I mean she planned it out.
She plans to divorce out for a long time.
It was incredibly calculating and the idea that men don't deserve rights and
because of the fact that women have been marginalized,
which is true,
they have been,
but that doesn't mean that men haven't been either.
I mean,
human beings deserve to be treated fairly.
That's just true to you.
You deserve,
everyone deserves to be treated humanely.
I don't believe men are,
I don't believe women are,
I don't believe humans are.
But the idea that you could separate and be a feminist,
but the anti men's rights,
well,
you're a fucking crazy person then.
You know,
you're not a humanist.
You're not a person who's looking at all human beings as your brothers and
sisters.
You're a person with that agenda.
You're a a person with an ideology.
And that ideology is that you're on a team,
you're on team vagina and everything that's on TV.
Penis can go fuck itself.
And that was the,
that was the,
the feedback.
The blow back that I got for a joke about male feminists.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I've stepped on that landmine a couple of times and I keep going back to
it cause it is,
it is an important one.
A young man in the legal system.
I mean not just with divorce but I mean the sentencing disparities between men
and women,
what they call the Pussy Bass,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's horrendous.
I mean you call Feminism Marxists with Penny's socialism,
socialism,
the original prop,
the socialism with tests.
But that was a bad character and one of my novels,
but I just call it the feminism.
Socialism is Panisse and it's very true because I mean,
and then people call,
oh my God,
that's so terrible.
Design.
I just went through all the founding matriarchs of the feminist system that all
Marxists,
all leftist and so on.
And also if feminism is so pro woman,
then where are they with Margaret Thatcher?
Margaret Thatcher was like the first leader of a Western country.
She struggled that from nothing.
I made an incredibly powerful woman,
but she was on the right,
you see,
so they hate her.
What about Iran?
I ran,
wrote,
wrote the most influential book outside the Bible and the second most
influential book in according to The New York Times review of books after the
Bible,
uh,
you know,
reshaped a western philosophy in many ways and western politics and the feminist
hater.
Why?
Cause she was on the right cause he's,
that's what they think.
She was not actually on the right but so I mean I have these sort of suspicions
when they're sort of the,
is it the leftist ideology or the pro woman?
Now if it's the pro woman then they should be incredibly positive.
Where are the feminists when people insult people like and culture.
Where are the feminists when people insult Sarah Palin,
you know,
like Bill Maher,
her called her a cunt.
I mean that's really pretty vicious.
Like publicly,
openly,
right?
I mean where are the fee because they're on the right and culture are considered
to be on the right.
So they get a pass when people go,
you know,
but you then say something bad about a woman on the left.
And so I think that it is more left than it is pro women because when they
choose between their politics and the agenda,
they always seem to choose the politics over the agenda.
And that's why I say it's leftist rather than than pro woman.
I agree.
And I think there's a lot of really emotional and non objective thinking
attached to feminism and there's a lot of,
there's a lot of really strange.
The,
the,
one of the more recent ones that I find incredibly strange is this,
uh,
there's this new trend of accusing men of rape if they have sex with a woman
who's had something to drink.
This is a,
uh,
like a,
a broad sweeping thing that's going through the Internet.
And a lot of these,
uh,
it's really weird because it seems to be,
there's a lot of it in this,
what they call a skeptical community.
And I,
the skeptical community seems to be of like integrated with a lot of male
feminists and feminist and this is something that they've adopted this idea that
somehow or another skepticism and this idea,
uh,
that they,
that they combine.
And it's,
I don't know if you're aware of of the case,
the Michael Shermer thing,
you know about all that accused,
uh,
some significant sexual impropriety,
right?
Yeah.
No evidence other than a person who doesn't want to reveal their name.
Who,
he,
the guy who wrote the piece heard about second hand.
Yeah.
He didn't even hear about it directly from the person.
And this is the person who's supposed to spell it.
They not see,
I don't understand is,
and he is getting sued now,
but it's the idea of that being the skeptic community.
I mean,
one of the things you learn as a skeptic when you're breaking down any idea,
whether it's a religious idea or whether it's an idea about,
uh,
an event that took place is that a person's eye witness account of any
individual event is suspect.
And that it's one of the worst forms of,
of evidence.
And it doesn't mean that a terrible thing didn't happen with this person,
but it does mean that if you look at the,
in the context of the way it was explained in this guy's blog is that she was
put in a position where she couldn't consent.
Like what?
What kind of Weirdo language is that?
And then the,
the corroborating evidence that he uses in this blog is that a woman went to a
party with this guy and he kept giving her drinks and he was flirting and that
she got drunker than she usually does.
And that's it.
That's the corroborating piece of evidence that the man and a woman who are both
adults were drinking together and she got drunk.
I mean,
I,
you talk about removing yourself a personal responsibility that he,
this guy was responsible for you getting drunker.
Like that's insane.
Like that's insane for a person to say this and we'll be drinks.
What choice did I am feminist?
Like,
why would you,
how is it possible that a person who believes in the,
in the power of being a woman could think that a woman is so much weaker than a
man,
that she can't control how much liquor she consumes when she's around a man?
If the man somehow or another like being with her and drinking with her forces
her to consume more than she normally would,
that's madness and there's no excuse called I was drunk.
I mean try that with drunk driving,
right?
It's all points that,
okay,
yes,
you had diminished capacity while you were driving,
but you were responsible for drinking and getting in the car.
It's the one time when we're willing to alleviate someone of their own personal
responsibility and only women.
A man is more a man who if a man and man is more responsible if a man of women
or drunk together,
but the woman feels bad about the encounter in the morning,
the man raped,
maybe all the man was drunk as well,
but the men are always the aggressors and always therefore guilty.
I mean that's not humanism,
but that has taken,
and this is a long dock road,
uh,
that as a man and you know,
I'm sorry that if you're a woman,
it's really hard to get this.
We have had so much negativity over the past 40 or so years,
pearls and masculinity that,
I mean,
we were like half criminals just for breathing.
if you look at the,
the role models on TV,
how,
how men to portray,
you know,
the homeless Simpsons and the American Dads,
they deck would all just idiots and sex trace and irresponsible and stupid at
the amazing thing is that it's true that if you look at the belcove intelligence
for women,
it's kind of spikes in the middle of so many more women are average intelligence
than men.
Now you still have your brilliant women,
you still have your done with it.
But if you look at the bell curve of male intelligence is much flatter,
which means that we have a lot more geniuses and allot my complete idiots,
right?
And what's happening is everybody's focused on the idiots among them.
And if completely began to ignore all the brilliance that men bring to the
world,
all of the amazing,
incredible inventions that men bring to the world.
And it's just with focusing on this low cluster,
which is incredibly biased.
It's like saying,
okay,
well blacks in America,
they commit more crimes and we're just gonna focus on that and say that's
all the blacks are.
That's all we're going to portray as blacks,
as criminals and blah,
blah,
blah.
That would be incredibly racist.
But the sexism of portraying men as idiots because we happen to have more
cluster as a gender on that side and completely ignoring all of the incredible
stuff that brilliant men bring to the world.
It's incredibly sexist and it's really hard for,
for for people to see.
I mean like the idea that the,
we were talking earlier,
the idea that a woman can competently raise children without a man around.
It's just taken for granted.
Now,
it's absolutely not true matter of essential to the healthy raising of children,
but the idea that we would recognize that as a society,
it's just we were just the disposable,
very unfortunate situation.
We're in in regards to feminism that uh,
a lot of people are dealing with their own personal experiences that they've had
with a few asshole men in their lives in regards to them not being sexually
attractive or not fitting into a certain social group or not.
And then they have somehow or another extrapolated that that all men are pieces
of shit and rapists or a massive amount of need to be curved and laws need to be
changed.
And if you get drunk with a girl and you have sex with her,
you're a rapist.
Right?
And a lot of this is based on their own negative interactions with men.
And this stereotype of feminism unfortunately is like,
there's a meme online,
this is feminism and it's a woman who,
uh,
has a,
um,
the,
uh,
of,
of holding up a sign saying I'm a feminist and she's fucking 300 pounds.
And you know,
and everyone's like,
yeah,
that's feminism.
You know,
like this is,
yeah,
you're right,
it's a big fat are going to go that no one's a fuck.
That's really unfortunate.
But the person,
the type of person that is a large,
unattractive woman is going to deal with and uh,
in measurably,
it's going to be so much harder for,
for her to find people who are sexually attracted to her,
for her to find a healthy relationships for her too.
If you,
it's an unfortunate reality in this world is that if you are not sexually
attractive,
you are not going to have,
is easier to ride when it comes to the opposite sex.
It's just a fact.
Well,
I mean,
but sexually attractive and 300 pounds,
somebody who's 300 pounds,
he is for most people got gotta be sexually unattractive.
But if they chose to lose weight and exercise,
that's sort of a different matter.
And that's just kind of have a basic human competence.
But one of the things that I hadn't thought of it,
like I grew up with a,
a single mom and we lived because single moms are used to be broke,
right?
I mean,
because it's a tough life.
And so when I grew up with a single mom,
everyone around me has single moms as well.
You know,
what's interesting is that the kind of man who float through single mom world,
they're not always the best kind of men,
right?
They kind of trashy,
Because like the really competent and successful and intelligent men aren't
trawling the girlfriend farms at the single mom.
You know,
they'll rent housing getups.
Right?
And so I think what happens is a lot of these women have grown up in single mom
households or,
or in this sort of environment and see who the men who floating through that,
they tend to kind of be losers.
They tend to be pretty unstable.
They tend to be kind of parasitical.
They,
you know,
they don't tend to be very,
the very best specimens of,
of masculinity.
And so I think the breakdown of the family,
he has created an environment where a lot of girls growing up don't have a
positive male role model in their life.
And the kind of men that they see floating through their moms,
dads tend to be kind of trashy.
So they're like,
well,
this is masculinity.
It's also very unfortunate that in their criticism of masculinity,
you've removed a lot of allies,
you know,
but by blanket generalizations of men,
you removed a lot of people like myself who I can't support you on that even
though I'm an entirely approach human being and,
and pro equality.
But when you make these mass generalizations and call someone a men's rights
advocate asshole like that,
these,
these are nonsense statements.
And it's unfortunate that I guarantee you these,
and it's not saying that all feminists,
feminists or unattractive or all feminists or uh,
you know,
uh,
not,
not sexually viable,
but I guarantee you almost all of them,
I've had a lot of negative experiences with men.
And it doesn't mean that all men are negative.
And it doesn't mean that there's not people out there that you would assume
would be assholes,
are actually very nice people.
But you've got this,
this idea that's,
it's easier to define the world by these rigid dimensions that you've sort of
set up for yourself.
And when,
when I,
when I read things that are from this feminist point of view,
there's so often aggressive and it's so often,
and I get that there's a blowback.
I do get that.
I get that they've experienced marginalization.
They believed that,
you know,
society is set up to support rape culture and all these strange ideas and that
there's a blow back to it.
But I don't think that the way it's being handled is,
I think it's,
I don't think it's objective.
I don't think it's irrational and I don't think it's balanced.
And,
uh,
I,
I find it really weird when really intelligent people attach themselves to these
feminist ideas.
Yeah.
And,
and,
but the problem is,
you know,
in Canada here I had a guy on my show,
Greg can't bill Gehringer who wrote,
um,
uh,
at the end of the family.
And it was,
and he pointed out that there's a revolution that occurs.
I think that initially it's necessary.
And I think this is also with blacks in America too.
There's a revolution that occurs then is initially necessary,
but the whole point of a revolution is to defend itself to end,
right?
So yeah,
I mean there was stuff that needed to be done.
Obviously we've talked about the,
certainly the blacks and the 60s and some stuff with women's kind of different,
right?
So cause women,
there's always been this women and children first,
right?
Like the vast majority of the people who died on the titanic,
we're men offering up their lifeboats to women,
right?
Because there has been a sort of women and children first,
and women have been kind of elevated.
There was no black people for us in the south right there.
So it's a little bit different.
But there was,
I think,
some push for quality that needed to happen.
But then what happens is you get a lot of people who get heavily invested in
this course and they'd be,
becomes their ego,
their identity,
right?
Like I fight for black lives,
I fight for women's rights and so on.
But then what happens is society will often listen and respond in a positive
way,
and then what is that course begins to diminish?
And people are like,
you know,
supporting,
like,
I'm not going to support you the abolitionists course because slavery is ended.
Like I'm just not going to do with it.
It's over.
Right?
I mean,
there may be other problems,
but that's not the problem.
Right?
Like I know to support a lot of,
uh,
you know,
let's,
let's deal with polio victims because we've got this vaccine and we don't really
have polio victims anymore.
Right?
So the whole point of revolution is to defund itself,
to end for people to move on with their lives.
But what happens is when you haven't government,
you get these voting blocks and you get,
like in Canada,
over the last 10 or 15 years,
Katie government's given $300 million to feminist groups.
That's not coming from Canadian women or Canadian men for that matter,
because,
you know,
a lot of it's kind of been dealt with.
But these groups continue by by poking these scams and by continuing these
grievances and by finding the Trayvon Martin situation and blowing it up into a
race war and all this kind of stuff.
A lot of the stuff has been dealt with,
but because the government's still getting the money,
they still need to whip up these kinds of hysteria there just to justify their
own existence.
I mean,
the whole point of a revolution is to end the whole point of I want to deal with
measles.
It's get a vaccine and end measles.
You don't keep taking the same amount of money that year after year,
but if you have a government funding it,
then you have to manufacture these grievances,
which just keeps things going and getting worse.
The point of revolution has a resolution and resolution never seems to come
play.
It's never going to take place if you're approaches imbalanced and there's just
some things that are being some proponents of feminism or endorsing one of them
being the ability to withdraw consent equals rape.
The ability that you mean after the fact?
Yeah,
after the fact.
Yeah.
That's sending you can send it to you.
That's like me giving you my coffee and then judging you with theft when you
walk out the room.
Yeah,
take my coffee.
Oh,
officer that he stole my coffee because I changed my mind after the fact when he
left.
Well,
the idea is that a man can lie to a woman in order to get in bed with her and
then if she can prove that he did that,
but that he's a rapist because he tricked her with his words.
Yeah,
because of course women never lie.
I mean,
they don't use makeup.
They don't puff up their tits.
They don't ever
falsify any therapy.
You don't do anything like a man because he's wealthy and hope to get pregnant
with him either.
I mean,
I don't see any feminists that are decrying that and that's a,
that's a horrible front to womanhood.
I think that the only way that you could make a live in is to lie to a man and
make him get you pregnant so that you can get money from them.
From then on.
I mean,
we're feminist.
True feminists should be horrified by that,
which I'll focus on.
The false rape accusations,
false rape accusations,
which in some studies or 2030 or 40% of the study in the air force,
but they actually do,
even women who have withdrawn their accusations,
2030 or 40% of Rick Rick accusations in some studies,
who knows what it is universally are our fast.
I mean how horrendous that and women should be coming down so hard.
I'm wondering who make false rape accusations cause they make it so much harder
for the women who actually happened,
right?
Because then there's that problem or a false paternity.
And the problem with fall three prepositions are very few women fees face
repercussions for them.
No.
Am I in my book?
If you can,
if you accuse someone of a crime and you lied,
you get the punishment,
they would have gotten,
you should
player football
player who has recently been released,
uh,
that he got on tape,
this girl a admitting that she lied about him being him raping her and her
family received $1 million or $850,000 and now they,
you know,
they have to pay the money back.
But that's the extent of her punishment.
This guy went to jail for five fucking years,
you know,
and now he's just trying to re pursue recording and he'd still be there.
Well,
not only that,
he's just one of many.
I have three friends that were falsely accused of rape.
I also have friends that were raped.
I know that there's,
I know rape is real.
You know,
I have friends that have been roofing and you know,
got out of danger because someone recognized in been drug.
It's not,
it's very common.
You know,
rape is a disgusting,
horrible anti human crime.
And I,
I think rape is,
should be treated the same way as murderers.
You're,
you're denying someone their humanity.
You're doing,
you're taking away something,
some part of them,
you're removing a part of the w the who they are as a person.
It's kind of permanent.
Yeah.
Somebody you can get a new car,
but there's something about sexual violations that it's kind of a permanent
thing.
It's horrible,
but so is lying about it.
That's horrible to lying about.
A rape is just as hard a lot of it,
but often we get them in,
right?
Yes,
yes.
And this idea of this idea of withdrawing consent,
you know,
and it's somehow or another you could do that and turn a guy into a rapist
that's like hating thing that's uh,
you don't,
you,
what you're doing is you're,
you're,
you're hating someone who's manipulative.
You're hating someone who can con you into bed.
But that's been what men have been trying to do since the beginning of time.
Like you're eating of the game of courting a woman.
And there have been men that wear shoes that they would never wear watches me,
would never buy.
And cars.
They don't give a shit about an apartment that they decorate just to get the
woman to believe that they're like this.
It's all a alive.
My friend Brian,
we saw earlier tonight,
last night for sure.
Um,
Brian Callan,
so hilarious guy the first time,
if you over his house back when he was single,
he had Jack Kerouac on the road,
uh,
sitting on his night table open.
Anthony,
I'm a predator.
So I come over his house and like,
then she may have written that,
you know,
I,
I find weaknesses and people very quickly.
So I saw that.
I go,
you're not fucking reading that.
you're,
you're hoping a chick comes over.
And she sees that and she's like,
Oh,
you read so much at polling are amazed that he's there.
He started laughing.
He goes,
it's true.
It's true.
I decorate my house to pretend I'm smarter than I am.
I did that.
There was a Stephen Hawking's book,
a brief history of time or by the upper right.
And I had that on my end.
This woman,
I loved her to death.
We went out for a while.
This woman came over and she's like,
I call bullshit.
I call bullshit on stuff later,
and I'm like,
no,
no.
I've read it and she,
what she did is she went over and she opened it and it creates like an old boat
did it never made it open before us that didn't go with his spine was completely
unvetted that like,
you know what?
You got me.
That's embarrassing.
That's
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.